[Music]
Bachelor standout crystal nielsen
reflects on her rocky relationship with
re lion dyke jr ET spoke with her at the
shows women tell all reunion taping this
is her sign it could be the last fight i
thought that he felt he was disrespected
but i was able to cop to cool down and
see it from his side and i just wanted
that in return and I feel like is that
but how relationships are it's like
you're you know when things like hit the
roof and like it's able to be able to
walk away and see even the other person
side and be able to communicate through
it even in Paris I was like can you come
to my side re sent her home in Paris but
before that it was the now-infamous
bowling date on the bus on the way home
crystal literally like lost her mind
what happened on that bus crystal we
didn't get to see the footage I wanted
to see the footage of the bus I was just
really upset in hurts me and I was just
like I felt it my teammates that were
very disrespected and I felt that we
should take a stand and show re the him
pulling back his word in him dangling a
carrot for us to dance and perform and
then pulled it away it's not okay with
me
and I would never tolerate that in the
real world especially because that
experience I didn't behind it with the
girls we were close because of it and I
thought we were all so disrespected it
really affected me alright loved how
confident and strong I wasn't aggressive
in seeking time for him and he really
and assured that to me and so I
continued that which is what was working
and I feel that very much so ostracized
ostracize me from the other woman
because they felt I was being
disrespectful of them but yeah re told
me it was what he liked about me we'll
get more of crystal re and crystal come
face to face on women tell all
airing Sunday February 25th on ABC
[Music]